i saw this movie called something we
something unknown as doing we don't know
what where your former assistant said
that she couldn't reach you in africa so
she said deepak in her mind deepak call
me and then you called her.
it's called non-local a-causal
communication
otherwise known as
telepathy
how do you do that
you go blank is that right yeah that's
step one that's step one
once you go blank then you introduce the
intention
and it ripples across the ocean of
consciousness
i was going to try and get your email
but instead will you do that to me
sure i just want you to pop in and go
yeah
we can do that i'll be open to it sure
because you're a big tm guy i do tm as
well yeah i do mantra meditation you do
mantra meditation is your mantra a
secret
um
i'll tell you i would say
you were so close
you were so close as an i could see you
considering on one hand i would tell you
but it's not to the whole world right oh
but other people know it
other people know it yeah okay i'm
relaxed
how many syllables
i think i know which one you're rocking
one one final question this has been uh
this has been such a delight and i don't
want it to be over uh
california marijuana log
the marijuana law
i'm totally for it you're for it for it
you think uh you don't think the chronic
gets in the way of people's
enlightenment
well in actually in the beginning it can
give you a glimpse of enlightenment as
long as you don't get hooked to it
but
i think we'll save a lot of
crime
some new taxes increasingly alleviate
alleviate chronic pain and those who are
suffering from cancer and you know
it's less
problematic than say cigarette smoking
or alcohol addiction
so
there you go you know i i like the
governor i've known him for
many decades
he's an old hippie like me is he really
i gotta ask
mushrooms
not
not telling